um well first of all it's an absolute
pleasure to be here
when you're thinking about this subject
like any good
um teacher will tell a teenager as
they're learning to write essays
it's what do we actually mean by liberal
democracy
i think it's important not to to give
you just a broad definition at the
beginning just to talk about you know
just to set out what i mean
by it because i think without that it's
hard to to move on and move through so
so basically what i mean
is you should break this down into two
bits you've got the liberal bit you've
got the democratic bin
the liberal bit is that there is an
acceptance of
freedom within constitutional limits
for individuals that is i think the core
bit of the liberal bit
the democratic bit is not just
that majorities rule because you could
call that mob rule in one sense
but that there are protections and an
acceptance
that minorities also have views and
interests that need to be protected
that's the difference between you know a
quasi-democracy
where if you're in a minority you get
trampled on because you're you're a
minority
and a true democracy which is minorities
matter because they have intrinsic
sort of inherent value
and that i happen to think comes from a
sort of judeo-christian
tradition of each in every individual
is made in you know is made in god's
image i'm not saying that because
everybody
needs to believe that from a religious
perspective and i think historically
that's where
we have come from that's where we've
built his liberal democracy around
but there is a third aspect to liberal
democracy that i think is important to
state at the beginning
and that is it is capitalist you know it
is not
a communist system it is not
a sort of more like fascist economic
model
it is a democratic capitalist system
and it is important that we remember
that that
is an integral part of liberal democracy
as well
so we've got to first of all set out
that it is
under threat it's under threat
in my judgment from from two sources
broadly speaking from above
and below where's it from uh
from under threat from above how is that
in several ways the first is it's under
is under threat internationally it's
under threat internationally
because there are major global actors
and i put china as the number one in
this
that fundamentally disagrees with this
model
even their version of capitalism isn't
the same they call it sort of state
capitalism it's a different
way of ordering society and
they are being very successful you know
you can't you can't pick up a newspaper
without people saying you know china are
doing this
they're doing that they're taking
millions of people out of poverty every
year the chinese growth rate's at seven
percent whatever it is they're
you know so they are appearing pretty
successful
and a lot of places in the world are
looking to china thinking
that looks like quite a good way of of
organizing things so it it is under
threat from
examples elsewhere from above it is also
under threat in broad terms from
a lot of countries within the west and i
use the united states
as one example but it's under threat
because
there are many people within the west
who look at
the model that we currently have and
again i think this has an economic route
often but it's also social in terms of
immigration
which combines with the the economic
they look at this and think maybe
this isn't the right system they don't
necessarily want the chinese system but
they say well
maybe the way we're doing things isn't
so great and then they
they say the reason for that because
their life isn't so great or
um they believe they can't get on in
life or they can't buy a house or they
believe they're too many immigrants in
their village or whatever
whatever the the concern is and the
third way
in which i believe it's under threat
from above and this is again where the
united states is pivotal and there's a
bit of a theme here
is the rules-based international order
that has prevailed broadly speaking
since the second world war
is no longer working properly because
the americans are failing to defend it
britain and europe are sort of going
through a few issues at the moment
europe itself even if you take brexit
out is actually divided in many
different ways
and whether it is the united nations
whether it's nato
whether it is even the world trade
organization that many of my colleagues
have a lot of faith in
actually the world trade organization
very soon
is about to run out of judges to
adjudicate disputes i don't know if this
is commonly known
the americans have failed to sign and
sign off judges for the last couple of
years which means
that even the world trade organization
soon is in danger of not being able to
operate properly
the whole way in which we've governed
things since the second world war is
under threat so
in one sense so i think it's under
threat from above it's also under threat
from below and this is something that
in fact i was taking at a panel um an
hour ago and i feel very very strongly
the impact of technology is only slowly
becoming apparent
the impact of technology and with that i
mean big tech and with that i mean mass
data and with that i mean
the fact that you can live in your own
digital echo chamber
to some degree you regard that as quite
funny we all say well you know on my
facebook feed
everybody voted remain or on my facebook
feed everybody voted brexit now we sort
of
we learned to live with that we find it
quite amusing but i actually think
it is the most pernicious thing that is
affecting our democracy now
because you no longer need to think
about people who do not agree
with you i'm 33 grand old age i know
and when i even 10 years ago
smartphones did not exist that we
facebook was in its infancy
you didn't get news from facebook 10
years ago there you did search on google
but you didn't have that personal
relationship with ideas that you have
now through your smartphone
and as a local mp i can tell you it is
the most dismaying thing in the world
when somebody says to me something
that's completely bonkers
and then they say but don't worry i read
it on facebook
and what you realize and i'm not
actually i'm not sort of
per se beating up on facebook i know
that you know it's one company it's it's
more what they represent
and what they are part of and so
if you have a system whereby
you no longer have to engage with in a
proper level
views that you disagree with you no
longer
start to respect the rights of
minorities
or what you perceive to be minorities on
that particular subject
and when that happens guess what you
quite quickly get to quite an illiberal
view and let me give you a very current
example now look i'm i'm a conservative
and i'm a conservative for many reasons
but one of them is that i believe in the
value of our institutions i believe in
the value of parliament the court system
the monarchy
i believe in that and i believe they
need to be defended
and i thought that was what all
conservatives believed in too
and yet sometimes and i can't see why
you're laughing i can't see what you're
thinking but sometimes people who i
would regard as conservatives who they
absolute you know
in their dna they will say well the
courts you know they're all lefties
you know we can just ignore them more or
whether it come to
you know something to do with even the
monarchy they may criticize if it's in
something else
or parliament well i mean it doesn't
really matter
what matters is the vote of the majority
and parliament doesn't really matter
because that
is less important than the vote of the
majority because
that is what the people have said
then you get to a place where your whole
liberal democratic
system no longer works in the way in
which it was designed to work
so my broad sense is it is being
attacked from above
and also attacked from below in a
bottom-up way
as an aside i might just say because i
was thinking about this and i'm a little
bit obsessed with this idea so
i don't even know if this makes it makes
sense even including this part of my in
my talk
but newspapers i was looking up the
history of newspapers and what
politicians did when newspapers came
around
they hated them they banned them for the
best part of 50 years and even when they
legalized them they imposed a tax on
them to stop people
reading them and so the only people who
could read them were the rich people and
there weren't enough of them to sort of
make a fundamental
difference in in democracy the reason
why and that was sort of late 17th
century i think the tax on newspapers
came in in 1711 1710 something like that
now the reason why i say that is we have
been through things in the past where
we've had new technologies come on board
and we've managed to deal with them so
and this is where i talked about the
solutions and the happy things okay
we've dealt with problems before where
we've got a new technology that has come
in
that those in power thought had ruined
everything
you know you were you're an mp for a you
know old serum or
wherever and you'd go back to see your
electors and there was some guy with the
printing press saying all sorts of stuff
about you and handing it around to
people
you can imagine the shock that that gave
a 17th century
political system but over time now we
regard newspapers as perfectly normal
within our democratic
framework so what i'm saying is when it
comes to technology i don't believe
i'm not one of those people that believe
there is inexorably we're leading to
doom and destruction
i don't believe that i believe that
where there is
political will and political will comes
from people will
you can change anything in this world
and i fundamentally believe that because
if i didn't believe that i wouldn't be
in politics
so this leads me on to my sort of last
section as to
what can we do about it and how do i
think it should be
changed so what can we do
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas